take that Supes no way because Superman
would totally melt Deathstroke's guns
with his heat vision in like two seconds
that's why Deathstroke carries a sword
can we just open up in just this game of
the year edition and fight this fight
for real I'd like to do that but we're
given that game away on today's show
after I play it with joven Chou from
Smosh games okay your replay news Bam
Bam Bam Bam King me you don't know how
to play chess - you know I do know
[Music]
so I'm a huge arrow fan and this season
has been amazing because they've been
introducing so many new characters and
I'm so happy to have Cynthia here
because they're introducing Amanda the
wall Waller
what have you done to really make this
character your own well it's really
wonderful about working on a series
based off a comic book there's just so
much material so as soon as I found out
that I was gonna play this character it
was like I'm gonna do some homework I'm
just some serious reading so doing some
research and getting ready for this
character there are any storylines that
you are hoping that you maybe get to
dive into what I think is really cool is
you know when we first meet Amanda
Waller initially we are we're not really
sure is she a good guy is she a bad guy
so that's kind of left a little babe so
I kind of liked that idea that you know
whatever you see Amanda Waller doing I'm
sure she has her reasons and she
probably thinks they're perfectly good
ones Superman Wonder Woman is both a
huge superhero team-up event and a nice
little love story was that really hard
to work I mean who would approve of
Supes right I mean the guy's got a lot
[Music]
it's really crazy with number two hey
guys I am here right now with Zack
Snyder and Kevin Smith this is just
after the live fan event talking all
about the Man of Steel DVD release first
off don't bury the lead we are standing
on a set from Man of Steel through this
Bruce Wayne's apartment know so being a
fan and being a director if you could
you know talk about any comic books that
you would hope to see a little bit of in
the next film here's what I think about
adapting comic books to film I don't I
don't want to see in this movie ninth
execs trying to do Frank Miller's The
Dark Knight Returns that will deserve
its own moving god willing one day he's
going to do now that we absolutely
somebody's gonna get there and if
anyone's gonna get there it's him you
were gonna do that you'd have it you'd
need a different Superman
so that's like we're bringing Batman
into the universe that that now this
Superman lives there think about how
many comic-book stories they've done
over the years in the hands of how many
different creators everybody having a
different take on it now you've got the
tools and filmmaking to actually make
movies that look like these kompozer so
rather than being like do the greatest
hits just show me everything I've ever
seen like let them do what every good
combo creator does takes the character
and does something original with it yeah
like that right now we're in the Man of
Steel frenzy because this is the Man of
Steel of our generation or this current
generation but ten years he's gonna
probably the village hey what do you
think of the new super moments where you
realize that your involvement in the
movie almost in a weird way diminishes
over time you know for me it does like
you I'm sure the second you make it like
I just made that and then over time it
if it's its own lives on its own now and
and that's really the fun moment for me
it's like when you first see it that
first day when you go like wow that's a
movie that moment is the moment and they
were able to do stuff he was able to do
stuff with this movie room like a hole
right they showed me something new I
hadn't thought about that this is a cool
addition this is that that to me is what
you do as an artist now take something
that exists and you're like I'm gonna do
something different with it I'm gonna do
what I do with it it was both
well guys make sure you check out the
DVD there's so many extras so much good
stuff watch it like 50 times like you
did so my first question is is this how
we're gonna have our office set up I'm
like thrilled I mean I know this is a
heavy decision but I'm thrilled as an
ocean to be finally be able to work with
you in one location
having United DC will mean some amazing
amazing things for the company I look
forward about from my standpoint the
more people we go the more DC remains
the same and the goal is to make sure we
saw the the same company and a better
company is your end of the day and I
could do the converse because you know I
see the energy and the excitement and
the growth that's coming out of the out
of the West Coast offices when you're
over there you hear about what's going
on on the TV and film side you hear
about the videogames and all those are
the things that are taking aspects of
the stories they're working on here and
bring them out there and
damnit I look at what's going on the
digital I get a little jealous dude you
know there's a tremendous amount of
resources and and support out in the
West Coast were able to put productions
like DC all-access together I mean that
was something that was worked out with
hella pictures and did not exist before
someone came off the idea of doing
something cool like this in a world
where the magazine business on the
newsstand business is collapsing or
books are shifting to digital we're
showing growth in both print and digital
our stuff is getting bigger so from my
standpoint it's a great time to be at DC
to be reading DC but more importantly
none of that's gonna change by making
the switch like that I think that's the
key messages that we get out of all this
is the fact that we're gonna be bigger
better and stronger as we see the as we
see the months and the beers turning and
I'm you know I'm hoping for a more
healthy run on this as we go for sure of
course man it's gonna be great it's
gonna be great so injustice Ultimate
Edition doesn't come out until November
12th but we did get our hands on the
game early because we are DC all-access
so I brought in joven shower here from
Smosh games because they're awesome to
games and I'm a glutton for punishment
and it's gonna what do we say earlier
hand me my ass yes I believe that was
the correct terminology alright good
good well I'm gonna pick cetana
cuz she's magic and I want to astound
you how about this whoa here I come I'm
a Manhunter I like that let me show you
this bad breath oh no sis that okay I
love the one sniper over there on the
yeah that Hummer he's gonna help hey
don't don't run from me I'm scared how
the car you know every pretty lady
should have a car I feel like you've got
your hands on an early because this is
not going the way that I had top man I
went all Superboy on you and actually
flew around the world ahead of time and
then grabbed it practiced up a little
bit a really stop with the magic
sparkler
I'm gonna be consistent for thee right
now I don't know how I'm accomplishing
this well here
now you're accomplishing nothing oh I'm
sorry I kind of kind of beat you there
come on my show and then like I beat you
in front of everybody no oh oh no I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna pull this off
there's no juggle - you did good if
anything you looked good buddy I did I
did
I like this back to basics that's
because you've lost a joshan injustice
yes yes it is do you think maybe with
your character choice you're probably
right you know we should do we should
have the fans tell us who the most
badass injustice character is and that
would help me hone my skills yeah and
they can just tweet us with hashtag DC
all-access will pick one answer from one
lucky fan and they're gonna win a signed
copy of game of erudition so many ways
to win okay well whoa you're thinking
everyone just makes sure to click this
link so you can find out who won the Man
of Steel DVD bundle from last week's
contest got it
[Music]
defeat is the true injustice yeah I felt
like to keep two directors on target
[Music]
[Music]